[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Jordan Belfort near I turned
26
I mean 49 million dollars in how much
money seventy two thousand last month
you showed me a paced up to 72 thousand
dollars on I quit my job right now and I
work for you Davis tonight I quit move
the money from your clients pocket in
the unified
[Music]
but if we can make it finds money at the
same time it's advantageous and everyone
correct now I started my own firm out of
an abandoned auto body shop
we will targeting the wealthiest 1% of
Americans I love briefings I love my
country I love Jesus Christ I love
making people rich hello was all this
legal absolutely no FBI any kind of
booze you might want out the bureau
forbids us to drink
[Music]
you just tried to bribe federal officer
[Music]
[Music]
$26,000 for one dinner dad we're not
poor anymore tell about the size size
that your cancer decides did cure cancer
that's the problem they weren't there
that's why they were expensive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]